من المؤكد أنه يقول إنه كان
من
الممكن فعل المزيد لإنقاذ
سيزان وحفيده الذي لم يولد بعد ،
آه
[موسيقى
] يبدو الأمر كما لو كان لديه
هاجس لما سيحدث في مجتمع يقول إنه
لا يقدر المرأة التي اتخذها
وظائف متعددة لتعليمها
حتى تتمكن من العمل وتعيش بمفردها
ولا تضطر أبدًا إلى الاعتماد على رجل
كان سردار قد توسل لابنته ألا
تتزوج
لكنها لم تسمع كانت تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا فقط
وفيما اعتقدت أنه حب
ثم قالت سردار  بدأ الضرب والإساءات ،
حيث تقدمت الأسرة بشكويين
أسفرتا عن أمر تقييدي
عادت سيزان للعيش مع والدها
إذا كان قد تم احتجازه لمدة ثلاثة
أشهر وستة أشهر ستبقى ابنتي على
قيد الحياة ، وحذر سردار من
أن زوج سيزان استدرجها
للاجتماع معه.  يقول سردار إن
طعنها 17 مرة
وقتلها وطفلها الذي لم يولد بعد ،
إذا كانت هذه القصة المأساوية فقط حدثًا نادرًا
في
مجموعات حقوق المرأة في تركيا التي تتعقب
معدلات قتل الإناث هنا ، يقولون
ذلك في المتوسط  تُقتل امرأة واحدة يوميًا على
يد شخص تعرفه
أحد أفراد أسرتها زوج صديقها حبيب
قبل ثلاث سنوات غول سيمبوستاجا ، بدأت إحدى
الناجيات من العنف المنزلي
فصولًا مجانية للدفاع عن النفس ،
يريد بعض أولئك الذين يحضرون حماية
أنفسهم من التحرش في وسائل
النقل العام أو في الشوارع
البعض الآخر في مواقف أكثر تهديدًا ،
لقد ولدنا في مجتمع
يسيء إلى النساء بسبب نظامه الأبوي
بمجرد أن نولد.
ومع
ذلك ، فإن الكثيرين يفعلون انسحاب تركيا من
اتفاقية اسطنبول ،
وهي معاهدة أوروبية لحقوق الإنسان تهدف
إلى إنهاء العنف القائم على النوع الاجتماعي ،
وهي هجوم على حياة المرأة. تقول الجرأة
إن المفارقة هي أن تركيا كانت في
الواقع أول
دولة تصادق عليها
[موسيقى]
والد سيزان  يقول إن
أعضاء ابنته ذُببت بسبب
طعنها المتكرر
لدرجة أنه لم يكن من الممكن التبرع بأي منها
سوى عينيها.
ope هي عيون
ابنتنا التي بقيت في العالم
يقول إن
شاء الله سترى العالم
بتلك العيون
تشعر العمة سانيا وكأنها مجنونة
وتقول إنها تريد أن تضرب رأسها
وتضرب نفسها فقط لإنهاء الألم فقط من
أجل ذلك  لإيقافها
، رفعت سيزان كعنصر لها بعد
أن تركت والدة
سيزان يديها بنفس الطريقة التي
أمسكت بها سيزان عندما
توسلت إلى سيزان من أجل الحقيقة حول
علاقتها
بزوجها المسيء سيزان الذي تم احتجازه
وينتظر المحاكمة وفقًا
للسلطات  النداء ليس علنيًا بعد ، فالأصل
الحقيقي ليس العدالة بمجرد ارتكاب الجريمة ،
إنه مع الأنظمة الاجتماعية والقضائية
التي تسمح لها بالوصول إلى هذا الحد.
أريد أن يعود طفلي ، أريد أن
يعود طفلي إلى
سانيا ويلز.  لا
تنسى
أروى دامون سيينا إزمير
[موسيقى]